[Musique]
cette déclaration commune ces jeux les
10 du cousu main
le 29 octobre dernier les présidents des
conseils départementaux du bas rhin et
du haut rhin
le président de la région grand est et
le premier ministre signé une
déclaration commune en faveur de la
création d'une collectivité européenne
d'alsace ce document premier acte d'un
long parcours qui verra la création en
2021 d'un super départements alsaciens
fixe les orientations pour la future
collectivité au coeur du projet un
certain nombre de compétences reçu de la
région et de l'état
parmi celles ci et non des moindres
l'intervention dans le domaine
transfrontalier en ce début d'année 2010
9 alors que le parcours législatif vers
la nouvelle collectivité suit son cours
les deux conseils départementaux lance
la stratégie hors visant à faire de
l'alsace un laboratoire européen en
matière de coopération transfrontalière
le coeur de ce projet de collectivité
européenne d'alsace la colonne
vertébrale
c'est l'europe eh bien nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui à travers la stratégie
or comme au bran bien montrer que le
bassin de vie l'avenir de l'alsace se
situe dans ce bassin de vie qui à celui
du rhin supérieur stratégie or comme au
bahreïn et rhin supérieur
elle vise à ancrer la future
collectivité dans l'espace trinationale
du bassin rhénan s'appuyant sur les
réflexions et expertises développées par
les deux départements
la stratégie se donne plusieurs grands
objectifs le renforcement du bilinguisme
l'attractivité des territoires
la mise en place de projets de mobilité
renforcer l'innovation pour la
transition énergétique et le
rapprochement des sociétés de part et
d'autre du rhin il ya toute une
dynamique économique à construire une
dynamique aussi culturel strasbourg et
capitales européennes l'alsace est un et
carrefour de l'europe c'est un potentiel
de développement pour notre territoire
toutes nos politiques doivent être
pensés à l'échelle rhénane c'est vrai
pour les mobilités c'est vrai pour les
formations d'où là les enjeux de
d'apprentissage des langues
on a toutes ces actions là à construire
la collectivité européenne nous donne la
légitimité pour le faire nous amis ont
lu allemands et suisses ont envie de
travailler avec nous et bien notre
volonté c'est d'avancer encore plus vite
sur ses actions la stratégie hors vista
prépare le terrain pour l'arrivée de la
collectivité européenne en 2021
si les objectifs visés par cette
dernière ne divergent pas des ambitions
affichées par les départements alsaciens
ces dernières années le cadre de la
future collectivité devrait permettre
d'aller plus loin plus vite et surtout
d'être un acteur à part entière de la
politique transfrontalière jusque là
chasse gardée de l'état un pas de plus
vers la décentralisation nous nous
aurons le leadership du transfrontalier
au travers d'un collectif européenne
d'alsace ça veut dire siéger aux côtés
du préfet dans toutes les instances du
rhin supérieur
et c'est la possibilité aussi de prendre
pour le compte de la collectivité
européenne d'alsace des projets qui ne
sont a priori pas de notre compétence du
fait de la loi nôtre mais de prendre un
autre compte des projets à partir du
moment qu'ils sont transfrontaliers de
l'autre côté du rhin en suisse et en
allemagne on est habitué à discuter et
travailler avec les différentes
collectivités françaises métropole
départements et régions chez nos voisins
on semble plutôt satisfait de voir un
nouvel acteur de proximité à paraître
dans le territoire et pouvoir porter la
coopération sur l'ensemble du territoire
alsacien
il ya un grand enthousiasme de la part
de nos voisins allemands et suisses
puisque ils savent aujourd'hui que leurs
partenaires dans leurs projets à
l'échelle du rhin supérieur
eh bien ça sera il est bien identifié ça
sera la collectivité européenne d'alsace
et en plus ce sera un partenaire la
collectivité européenne d'alsace qui
aura des compétences très forte
le président de la république a bien
reconnu le rôle stratégique de la
collectivité européenne d'alsace dans le
rat supérieur
au coeur des enjeux de la stratégie or
la place des alsaciens dans cet espace
culturel et économique qu'est le bassin
du rhin supérieur
aujourd'hui poids des chansons
bilinguisme ainsi la pratique de la
langue allemande ou du dialecte alsacien
doit être soutenue compétente en matière
de bilinguisme la future collectivité
prévoit de renforcer de l'apprentissage
précoce de la vie pour tous il est
vraiment de dynamiser ses politiques et
d'apprentissage de la langue régionale
dès la petite enfance en fait surtout le
parcours de l'élève
voilà pour que toutes les générations
puissent effectivement baigné dans un
nouvel environnement dialectal dans un
nouvel environnement de langues
régionales pour permettre à tous les
jeunes d'acquérir un minimum alors on
parle de 300 mo 300 mots allemands 300
mots qui leur permettront effectivement
de de pouvoir converser dans le
quotidien et pouvoir aussi entretenir
une discussion avec avec nos voisins
suisses ou allemands
dans l'actualité récente la signature du
projet franco-allemand de reconversion
du territoire de fessenheim est un
exemple des actions déployées dans le
cadre de stratégies or avec l'appui de
l'état français les collectivités et
leurs partenaires allemands vont ainsi
investir dans l'attractivité économique
l'innovation énergétique et les
infrastructures afin de faire de ce
territoire une vitrine européenne de la
transition énergétique le sens de notre
démarche c'est d'accompagner et de
soutenir les élus du territoire dans
leur projet c'est un bel exemple de
coopération concrète entre la france et
l'allemagne avec y compris des liens
futurs renforcée entre ces régions
voisines du bade wurtemberg et de
l'alsace un premier pas dans la mise en
place de la stratégie hors que les
départements espère bien voir avancer à
grands pas d'ici 2021